what's the best place to put solar
panels
well close to the sun of course
and in this scenario we're going to
build the most efficient solar farm
possible
and maybe just maybe
that would make us a type 2 civilization
on the kardashev scale
what would a sun orbiting solar farm
look like
how close to our star would we be able
to put the panels
and how would we manage to get all that
power
back to earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we put solar panels around the
sun
every second the sun produces more
energy than we humans have used in the
history of humankind
and every 90 minutes the earth receives
enough sunlight to power humanity for a
full year
only we're still far from gathering even
a fraction of all that energy
in 2021 of all the electricity we
generated only 3.1 percent came from
solar panels
even if we built more solar farms here
on earth
not all of the sun's energy would reach
us
our star is radiating energy in all
directions
and not all of the light that hits earth
even makes contact with our planet's
surface
some of it is reflected or absorbed by
our atmosphere and clouds
considering how much energy is lost
before the sunlight even reaches the
solar farms down on earth
it would be much more efficient to get
our solar panels somewhere they could
face the sun 24 hours a day
every day
harnessing all the sun's energy could
save you a lot of money but
is the risk worth the reward
well we won't know until we try but not
all investments are this way there are
many low risk investments out there but
just one that i'm particularly excited
about contemporary art yeah our sponsor
masterworks is the platform for
investing in art by legends like
basquiat and monet they purchase
financially attractive works they
believe will appreciate in value for
members to buy shares in they purchase
you invest they sell and they know what
they're doing the three paintings
they've sold have each returned over 30
percent net irr to investors you know
legally i do have to add past
performance is no guarantee of future
results but 30 percent that's incredible
similarly our prices have outpaced the
standard and poor's index
164
over the past 26 years
probably because these assets perform
better during periods of inflation
i've always been interested in art and
now i get to invest in it and for only a
fraction of what billionaire collectors
have paid skip the wait list by visiting
masterworks dot art slash what if or
click the link in the description below
to start investing
if you really wanted to maximize our
solar power potential you'd need to
start with building a lot of panels
solar panels are made of photovoltaic
cells or pv cells that convert sunlight
into electricity
and approximately 95
of the modules sold today are made of
silicone
unfortunately you'd have to manufacture
these cells on earth before bringing
your solar panels into space
and that transportation
would cost a pretty penny
to save on expenses you'd want to build
your solar panels with the lightest
materials possible
one idea would be to make your solar
cells with lightweight gallium arsenide
with this material you could build
individual solar cells each about the
size of your dinner plate
once you carried them into the earth's
orbit you'd put them together in blocks
as large as 60 square meters
that's about the size of four parking
lots
with a good supply of solar panels you
could now start planning their
arrangement around the sun
one model you could explore would be a
dyson sphere
that's a gigantic megastructure we could
engineer around the sun
the scientist who came up with this idea
actually
stole it from aliens
he theorized that a much more advanced
alien civilization built this hollow
sphere around their star to gather all
of its energy
so if those theoretical aliens could
rearrange their planetary neighborhood
like that
well we could do it too right
well did i mention that this dyson
sphere would have to be gigantic
yeah the distance around the sun or its
circumference
is about 4.4
million kilometers so we would need
millions if not billions of individual
solar panels to hug our sun
and our dyson sphere would need to be a
little further from the sun so that it
wouldn't touch its scorching hot surface
well maybe instead of building such an
impossibly massive structure you could
send a bunch of solar panels that would
independently orbit the sun
and over time more and more solar panels
could be added to create larger more
complex structures
surely there's no way the materials you
used to build your solar panels could
get anywhere near the sun without
completely melting right
well think again
nasa's parker solar probe traveled
through the sun's corona layer and
heated up to 1400 degrees celsius
impressive but that's frigid compared to
the temperature of the corona itself
it gets as toasty as millions of degrees
in there
yeah you wouldn't be able to get that
close to the sun unless humanity came up
with lots of super heat resistant
materials
forget about that but you could build
solar power stations a little further
from the sun
maybe somewhere halfway between it and
the earth
you'd still be able to receive enormous
amounts of power from there
theoretically if your space solar power
station was 10 square kilometers
it could power one and a half million
homes
compare that to earth's surface where
you'd need about 6 million solar panels
to generate the same amount of energy
speaking of supplying earth with power
uh how exactly would you manage to get
all that energy back to our planet so we
could use it
well your power transmission system
would have to be wireless and that would
mean using microwave radiation
you'd need to build massive antennae
your space solar farm would send
microwaves back to earth and here we
turned them into electricity
these antennae would take up a lot of
land but they'd become your favorite
scenic view
of course you could strengthen the
microwave signal from your solar farm
and use smaller antennae to catch it on
earth but this would come at a higher
risk
microwave radiation could heat your body
tissue the same way it heats food in a
microwave
that means a strong enough microwave
signal would cause painful burns
it could even cook you from the inside
out
and not just you
microwave radiation would roast anything
containing water
oceans lakes and rivers could start to
boil
if water reservoirs below the earth's
crust heated up enough the internal
pressure could result in the whole
planet exploding
but if you could get around these
terrifying downsides putting solar
panels in space
would be a huge advancement for our
civilization
it could even be a step up on the
kardashev scale
this measures how advanced a
civilization is based on the usable
energy it can produce
right now we're ranked as a type zero
civilization because we don't even
collect all of the energy from our own
planet
if we were able to harness all the power
of the sun through a dyson sphere or
solar panels orbiting it we'd jump up to
a type 2 civilization
that means we'd have more energy than we
could even imagine right now
and interstellar travel beyond our solar
system would become a real possibility
but we'd have to become a type one
civilization first
and you know what
that's a story for another
what if